The basic Arden unit is Medical Logic Modules,
MLMs, each of which contains sufficient knowledge to make a single clinical decision.
As illustrated here, MLMs used the Backus-Naur form, BNF,
a notation for context-free grammars,
otherwise used to describe the syntax of computer programming languages,
document formats, instruction sets, and communication protocols.
Each MLM can have four categories of information.
Maintenance, Library, Knowledge, and Resources.
This example from Dr. Ribshek illustrates two of these,
and I've highlighted them in yellow for you.
Here in the library category,
you see that the purpose of this MLM is to check
each new penicillin prescription for a penicillin allergy.
Here in the knowledge category,
you see that the triggering event is that
the newly prescribed medication belongs to the penicillin class.
Of course, the way to determine that might well be EHR-specific.
Here you see the logic to evaluate the decision,
and here, the action to take if its value is true.
There is now an Arden XML schema and this diagram of it details all four categories.
In addition to the two categories we saw earlier,
each MLM also contains management information to help maintain
the knowledge base of MLMs and links to other knowledge resources.
Health personnel can create MLMs and implement them in
any EHR or clinical information system that conforms to the Arden specification.
Keep in mind that each MLM can drive one decision,
so in practice, a group of MLMs may be required.
Here, five MLMs help provide clinical decision support for the use of warfarin,
a common but potentially dangerous blood thinner often
given to patients after thrombotic strokes caused by clots,
or to treat other potential blood clotting problems.
Too little of the drug may mean another stroke,
too much can cause excessive and even fatal bleeding.
Warfarin interacts with many other drugs and even the patient's diet,
so it is a tricky drug to manage.
Physicians use a test called PT/INR to assess the degree
of blood thinning to manage the warfarin dose in each patient.
You can see here that the modules,
using clinical data about the patient including their PT/INR,
can make warfarin dosage recommendations.
This part of the MLM specifically deals with a lab test,
the creatinine level, that measures kidney function.
It is important to know the patient's kidney function
before giving the dye because the kidneys remove the dye,
and it can cause kidney damage.
As a result, Arden needs to know the creatinine level.
And to get it, dam = PDQRES2 in curly braces, highlighted here,
must be interpreted by the EHR in
a particular hospital to fetch that value from its proprietary database.
The purpose of Arden is to share clinical decision support logic,
but because EHR have not been regularly interoperable,
the work involved in implementing Arden locally has led to low Arden adoption.
This impediment is so serious and widely known that it even has a name,
a curly braces problem.
This leads us to one of the key advantages of FHIR that I
mentioned earlier as a reason for this discussion of clinical decision support.
FHIR-enabled EHRs would present creatinine in a consistent form,
as a FHIR observation resource.
As a result, a hypothetical clinical decision support FHIR app
need have no knowledge of the EHR's internal data structure or representation.
It would not need to be adapted to each EHR,
greatly reducing development cost and facilitating implementation and hence,
the likelihood of clinical decision support adoption.
We will discuss integration with workflow and process.
The second major advantage of FHIR and SMART on FHIR
in support of clinical decision support in the next lesson.